one division proves that you don't
always necessarily need to jump into the
meat of a story
you can take your time forcing the
audience to question your motives
and speculators to wear precisely your
heading that was the case with episode
one of the hit disney plus original as
the series followed a pretty
straightforward
sitcom plus with each passing episode
the audience receives more information
until the explosive final scene
in episode five when wander and vision
hear a knock at the door
and discover it's wander's brother
pietro only it's not the mcu
quicksilver played by aaron taylor
johnson who bit the dusting age of
ultron
it's evan peters who played the
superhero in the 20th century studio's
x-men movies
we've known for a while that peters
would make an appearance on one division
resulting in rampant fan theories that
his presence would open up the gates
between the marvel cinematic universe
and the larger marvel multiverse which
includes the x-men
however given his brief introduction
there's still a lot we don't know
is this actually the quicksilver we last
saw in x-men dark phoenix
is this a different guy who happens to
look like evan peters and what did darcy
mean with this line
she recast pietro things are only going
to get crazier from here as we get into
the final four episodes
fortunately show creator jack schaefer
sat down with marvel.com to discuss the
phenomenal casting coup
and how exactly it came to be by the
sound of it schaefer knew early on she
wanted to try to bring peter's
quicksilver back
but naturally that led to a fair share
of challenges as she explains
that's the thing you can hatch a million
great ideas but to make them land
to make them be grounded to make them
feel organic to the larger story
this sentiment and the idea that has
rolled out to make sense in the overall
structure of the series was echoed by
marvel studios president kevin feige
schaefer continued kevin wanted to make
sure that there was a reason for it that
it made sense and i hope that's what we
did
it's safe to say the mission was
accomplished and given the fact that
vision actor paul bettany has said that
a massive cameo
would be coming down the line
quicksilver's entrance won't be the only
thing that blows our mind with this show
it's such a trippy series that it would
be easy to go overboard with craziness
but grounding things in some definition
of reality helps keep the show honest
schaefer further expounds upon this
saying this show is such a mind scramble
and because it's working on so many
levels and there's so many notions of
what's real and what's not and
performance and casting and audience
and fandom and all of that we just
thought it would be the biggest thrill
to bring evan over to the marvel
cinematic universe all questions
regarding where exactly this new
quicksilver came from and what his role
will be going forward
will receive answers eventually and for
the time being we already have a good
idea of what his role in the sitcom
world will be
darcy's saying that's wonder recast her
deceit's brother wasn't just a throwaway
line
recasting characters even prominent ones
in sitcoms is a common trope that can be
seen time and time again
just take bewitched which replaced dick
york with dick sargent as co-lead
halfway through the series
of course modern audiences may be more
familiar with janet hubert witton
to part in the role of aunt viv on the
fresh prince of bel air
after feuding with star will smith and
getting replaced with daphne maxwell
reed
replacing taylor johnson's quicksilver
with evan's version just makes sense
one division had to recast pietro to
further solidify its sitcom influences
and it undoubtedly sets up some bigger
surprises in the weeks to come
to see how all this plays out keep
checking in with one division every
friday on disney plus
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic characters are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one